bonjour madame
bonjour il y a eu des consultations
publiques en septembre et en octobre
est-ce que c'est ce que les gens avaient
demandé d'avoir cette zone tampon et
d'avoir des déménagements
en allant c'est vraiment un échec de la
consultation ce qu'on voit là on a eu
aucune consultation sur trois lois de
déménagement des personnes ce qui a eu
dans la consultation c'est le plan de la
fonderie alors comment on réduirait
progressivement puis on n'était pas
d'accord avec ça parce que ça prenait
trop de temps avant d'arriver au fameux
15 nanogrammes dont on parle on s'était
dit qu'un 15 ça pouvait s'atteindre de
peut-être la première année mais après
ça il fallait continuer d'aller vers le
trône comme pour le reste du de la
province donc vous avez été consulté sur
une prémisse qui était on cherche une
façon pour que les gens puissent
continuer à vivre dans leur quartier et
faire de façon sécuritaire sur le plan
de la santé
tout à fait mais là on nous arrive la
santé publique avait quand même dit la
direction santé publique avait dit aussi
si cette condition les conditions sont
pas atteindre rapidement il faudrait
voir comment on peut protéger les gens
parce que on était du conscience du côté
de la santé publique que c'était pas
normal que les gens arrivent avec autant
d'harsenic dans l'air et autant des
autres métaux alors il y avait eu cet
élément là nommé par la santé publique
mais c'est comme pis aller c'est comme
je pense que la première étape c'était
de négocier pour vrai avec l'entreprise
de ce qu'on semble pas avoir de ni de
résultats en tout cas la lumière des
informations qu'on a qu'est-ce que vous
comprenez alors pourquoi votre avis le
gouvernement choisi cette voie choisit
finalement de délocaliser les gens
écoutez pour nous si on s'entraillit on
sent pas considérés on s'est citoyen de
deuxième troisième zone on comprend pas
que il y a eu un choix de fait en lien
avec une entreprise qui est capable que
les rins solides et qui seraient
capables d'investir plus rapidement on
est sûr qu'il y a des moyens techniques
pour arriver plus vite aux résultats
qu'on prévoit dans trois quatre ans cinq
ans c'est pas exactement encore on va
savoir ça demain alors on n'a pas je
pense que le gouvernement a pas poussé
assez fort pour que on soit respecté
alors on tasse les gens plutôt que
d'exiger des améliorations importantes
de la part de la compagnie puis vous
voir que c'est pas d'hier là qu'on sait
on a appris que c'est pas d'hier en 2004
il y avait eu des recommandations d'un
comité d'experts textologue
métallurgiste tous ces gens-là disaient
qu'il fallait que ça change en 18 mois à
l'époque on demandait de baisser à 10 en
18 mois ça a pas été écouté ça a été mis
sous le tapis et puis on nous arrive
presque 20 ans à attendre encore 5 ans
10 ans avant d'arriver à la norme
provinciale il y a un travail qui a été
fait et non seulement avec Lancôme
milliardaire cette entreprise-là c'est
gigantesque alors non seulement on ne
baisse pas dans un délai qui que vous
trouvez acceptable à 15h parce que on va
le faire sur plusieurs années on
n'atteint pas la norme du Québec qui est
de 3 nanogrammes ont délocalise les gens
mais en plus ça va coûter de l'argent au
gouvernement c'est 85 millions quand
même pour construire un nouveau quartier
que ça a pas de bon sens on fait vivre
aussi aux gens du quartier actuellement
un stress important parce que vous savez
c'est un des éléments importants de
stress dans la vie le les déménagements
les séparations etc c'est que ces
gens-là actuellement leur en prix en se
réveillant le matin après avoir écouté
la Souris verte décédé on apprend qu'on
déménage que qu'on va se faire
délocaliser ça sera pas toujours au
lendemain on en a pour quelques années
sûrement avant d'arriver à installer les
gens dans un nouveau quartier là je on
ne sait pas encore parce que on sait que
les logements sont rares ici que les
espaces sont pris on peut imaginer que
ces gens-là qui ont pas de voiture parce
que dans le quartier beaucoup de
personnes ont pas de voiture il était
proche des services proche de proche des
écoles proche du centre de santé d'ici
etc et qui vont se retrouver avec des
dépenses supplémentaires ou loin des
services comment ça va se passer comment
ils vont être accompagnés on entend rien
de tout ça on entend de l'argent pour la
ville pour installer un quartier mais on
n'a rien entendu pour que les citoyens
soient accompagnés par exemple par des
avocats par des travailleurs social
c'est un drame pour eux c'est qu'il
faudrait prévoir toutes sortes de
services autour de ça mais on fait une
annonce on laisse filtrer des données
avant d'expliquer le contexte puis les
gens se retrouvent stressés avec cette
situation là et non respectée clairement
alors ces domaines alors officiel du
ministre de l'Environnement la ministre
de la ferme municipale aussi va être là
est-ce que vous allez essayer d'entrer
en contact avec eux qu'est-ce que vous
allez faire ça se fera quoi pour vous la
suite des choses
mais on va essayer de savoir aussi on a
appris que ce serait trésor demain
j'apprécie tantôt sur les zones de
Radio-Canada alors c'est sûr qu'on va
tenter de d'avoir des informations
supplémentaires la date on en a pas eu
tout ce qu'on a c'est par les médias on
a on avait rencontré la nouvelle
personne qui va faire le lien le madame
Guilhem qui remplace madame Protot le
changement d'administratif d'État qui
est au ministère des municipalités le
fait une rencontre bon un peu social il
y a à peu près trois semaines mais on
n'a pas eu d'autre suite il y avait un
comité de suivi des études de bio
surveillance qui était déjà en place ou
tout les acteurs étaient là on n'a pas
eu de rencontres de ce comité-là on nous
espérez qu'il va y avoir
des liens avec la communauté il semble y
en avoir eu avec la ville mais vraiment
à micro fermé on est pas au courant de
rien on était au conseil municipal au
début de la semaine puis on avait pas
d'informations supposément mais on peut
imaginer qu'ils en avaient parce que à
48 heures on a les conseillers font du
porte-à-porte donc il y a quelque chose
qui se passe
évidemment pour l'annonce et pour les
autres réactions merci beaucoup madame
de gagner elle m'a fait plaisir au
revoir au revoir